i am at right click and save which is an
exhibition of digital art being put on
here in singapore
the primary motivation is really
community building nfts have had a
renaissance over the last 12 to 15
months but there's still a substantial
part of the market that's not familiar
with the ecosystem we want to really
raise awareness to this new medium and
to hopefully engage curious enthusiasts
new collectors and artists too it's
pretty exciting there's a beeple on
display that's the guy whose work sold
for 69.3 million dollars at auction
earlier this year and a lot of pretty
big names making people happy over there
we have a btcc block but at the back
there's actually a private key that
unlocks to the bitcoin that this
holds this work is people's so beeple
set himself out on this project where he
would create a new drawing every single
day and this and continuation of that
project this is day
5042.
making people happy this work was
initially created in 1985 by andy warhol
he created several digital paintings the
work
was retrieved in 2014 and they kind of
restored the file from floppy disks to a
technology that is accessible today
sculpture is a collaboration between
coin hakko and mighty jax my t jacks is
a
toy and collectible manufacturer
it's uh we're created out of resin and
the hand-painted and there's only one of
such in the world and of course it's
about the doge
[Music]